[Music]
hello and welcome to our very first
spotlight i hope you enjoyed the opening
keynote for the next hour we will be
diving into all things data i'm
stephanie wong a developer advocate and
i'm here with garrett kasmeier who leads
database analytics and bi solutions at
google cloud
thanks stephanie i'm very excited to be
here and to share with everyone what we
have been working on
the team thought we start on the light
side of things here and start with a
joke one of my favorite jokes actually
so
here it goes a secret query walks into a
bar
and approaches two tables and asks
can i join you
[Music]
okay i guess we wrote a video instead
innovation is a huge challenge in
baseball the current mlb fan expects us
to be relevant customers call us
patients call us members call us and you
can imagine a team that's just buried
under the weight of thousands of call
recordings
we look at so much data everything you
can imagine we analyze frankly we spend
70 percent of our time just trying to to
capture it and trying to sift through it
we're expecting to
transfer around 300 to 400 petabytes to
the cloud
it's hard to even describe how big that
is
google cloud was very impressive to us
it allowed us flexibility in storage and
compute scaling google cloud provides us
with technology that will drive us to be
better
now our team can look at hundreds of
calls a day in minutes instead of weeks
with google cloud we're going to be able
to spend our time analyzing real time
and using the data that we've been
collecting
we thought google cloud was the best
partner for us i think this is very much
going to be an open and evolving
long-term relationship between google
and twitter it's a perfect fit with
google cloud as we go forward google's
made it possible for us to reach
exceptional customer experience in a way
that hasn't been done before
[Music]
and welcome back so what are we solving
for today this spotlight session is
about how to leverage data as your most
strategic business asset especially as
you adapt to and anticipate change
data has the power to transform stagnant
businesses into profitable ones
streamline operations to improve
people's lives and identify areas of
waste to radically reduce unnecessary
spending
it can be used to solve businesses and
world problems both the simple ones and
the ones that keep people up at night
it has the potential to accelerate
progress faster than a think tank or
world summit
and it's largely untapped
as you learn more about google cloud
capabilities and make progress on your
data cloud journey you can unlock your
own 10x mindset as external factors
accelerate the pace of change
never before have we faced this much
uncertainty and now is the time when
every company can turn data into an
ability
the reality today is that too many
companies struggle to remove the
barriers to turn data into intelligence
this is exactly what we are seeing with
our customers turning data into
intelligence and delivering value is no
longer a nice to have it is essential a
recent study shows that only 32 percent
of the companies surveyed gain value
from their data investments and this is
the result of difficult to access slow
unreliable complex and fragmented
systems
many companies just feel overwhelmed
with the demand for the various types of
working with data and of doing it at
scale they feel walled in with a lack of
integration a lack of openness a lack of
portability and very poor apis
it is time to reimagine our data cloud
strategy that is unlocking your data
advantage
build great applications that understand
and interact with your customer on
operational databases that scale to
billions of queries per second
react on any event in real time and
process millions of data streams
analyze petabytes of data without sizing
or tuning your data warehouse anymore
and ultimately optimize your processes
with hundreds of machine learning models
in production
this is how you unlock your data cloud
and unlock your data advantage
to build your data cloud you need your
systems to be simple
and this requires a partner that meets
you where you are today and helps you to
mature where you want to be
but at your own pace
making the complex simple is our
business
it has been for decades building systems
that mask the complexity of the entire
internet behind a simple single
interface and building applications with
billions of users
it all runs on data and analytics so you
can say the data is our dna
and we can't predict the future but we
can plan for it and we are deeply
grateful to work with tens of thousands
of organizations who build their data
clouds on google cloud
and unlock ultimately their data
advantage from databases to analytics to
streams to lakes to ai
and build a unified data cloud together
with us
it's leaders like you who are
accelerating their use of data to
transform complexity into simplicity
this week at next you'll hear from
leading organizations that have chosen
google cloud for their data cloud
strategy over market alternatives
verizon media is one of these customers
verizon uses bigquery and looker to
scale their massive enterprise media
warehouse supporting monthly scans of
more than one exabyte of data
the performance improvements include
90 percent plus productivity
improvements across the board and lower
overall tco compared to other cloud
providers
almost overnight traffic to chess.com
tripled the pandemic and successful
series the queen's gambit created a
perfect storm
ten years worth of growth occurred in
just six months and daily active users
rose from 280 000 to more than 1 million
there's no way to handle that search
without the move to google cloud using
bigquery's near infinite ability to
scale in response to demand this meant
that chess.com didn't have to forecast
site traffic and worry about unexpected
surges or waste money by over
provisioning servers that go unused take
autotrader it's uk's largest online
automotive marketplace and they were
able to migrate more than 60 of their
current oracle footprint to cloud sql
autotrader builds their data cloud by
leveraging cloud sql bigquery and looker
to deliver access to their data to all
of their users and with cloud sql as a
fully managed service auto greater
release cadence has improved by over 130
percent year over year enabling an
impressive peak of more than
450 releases to production
on a single day and this is how you
build your data advantage
when cardinal health migrated to google
cloud they enabled disaster recovery
increased their ability to respond to
business challenges and leverage machine
learning to drive business efficiencies
all while reducing their cost by 25
we would like to welcome ray bajaj cto
of cardinal health to share their data
transformation story
ray thank you so much for joining us
here today
thanks stephanie and i'm really happy to
be here today cardinal health is a
pioneer in healthcare industry for
leveraging the cloud as a primary source
of infrastructure
achieving our cloud transformation
journey goal
with more than 80 percent of our
workload fully migrated onto the cloud
our journey to google cloud started in
2018 leveraging the security and
flexibility of google cloud
allows us to scale and innovate at lower
cost
which empowers our organization to focus
on building the future of healthcare
and driving better outcomes across the
healthcare ecosystem so
why google cloud
with google we can deliver modern data
insights capabilities
to our engineering teams so that they
can transform our core business
while also improving the customer
experience
helping the organization evolve
in the adjacent areas of healthcare
we also selected google cloud because of
its ability to partner with sap
and run massive erp workloads reliably
now what outcomes have you been able to
realize as a result of this
we leveraged google's local and bigquery
to develop episode analytics a data
driven predictive cost tracking tool
that enables community oncology
practices to accurately measure
the cost of care and provides clearer
insights
into value-based performance
well ray cardinal is clearly at the
forefront of these shifts and we can't
wait to see what's in store for you so
thank you so much for being here with us
today
thank you
organizations like cardinal health are
solving complex challenges with google
cloud
but
what is holding others back from using
data to accelerate innovation
companies are looking for solutions that
can simplify their data landscape to
move from a state where every scenario
requires a new tool to an agile platform
that combines data analytics databases
data engineering and science security
and governance into a single platform to
move from data at rest to a platform
where data is accessible in real time
our vision is to provide a platform that
allows data to unfold its full potential
ultimately enabling us to reach new
horizons ranging from newly built
digital experiences products and
business models to advanced machine
learning and ai to ultimately empowering
humans to reason beyond their own
biological capacity
and we have built the industry's most
simple intelligent and best integrated
cloud data platform that enables
businesses to fuel their own digital
transformation
and this is how you unlock your data
advantage
to seize new opportunities improve
operational efficiencies and deliver new
user experiences that delight customers
partners and your employees
thanks to you our customers and partners
google's data platform is one of the
fastest growing clouds fueled by the
demand for products like big query and
here comes the most exciting part today
we are excited to announce a number of
new product innovations
and the first announcement goes out to
all of the data engineers in the world
who are using spark on google cloud open
standards are at the heart of our data
cloud strategy and at google we follow
an open approach that enables
flexibility and choice and today i am
excited to announce project big spark it
is the world's first auto scaling
serverless spark service in existence
and regardless of whether you are a big
query user a data proc user our cloud ai
user we have created an integrated
ecosystem around spark the de facto
standard for data engineering workloads
we want to make it easy for you to
onboard on our platform with spark and
never limit your ambition with data
science and data engineering
our long history in the open source
community has shown us that betting on
the community first is always the right
strategy to give our customers
portability and optionality we're
excited to make spark a first-class
citizen on our platform and to automate
the productionalization of your data
engineering and data science workloads
the next announcement goes to all of the
data scientists
as enterprises consolidate their data
platforms the distinction between
advanced analytics and data science and
machine learning is really diminishing
today more than ever data scientists are
looking for a unified interface to be
able to seamlessly connect their entire
data estate and also run all
explorations with sql spark and other
machine learning libraries with vertex
ai we have simplified the experience for
data scientists with 80 percent less
code required to drain a model compared
to any other platform
as a part of google's vertex ai strategy
i am happy to announce the brief view of
ai notebook for vertex ci that offers a
fully managed scalable and enterprise
great ide combined with easily
enforceable policies and user management
these ai notebook innovations are great
examples of google bringing together the
power of data and ai
google truly aims to fast-track
innovation by eliminating the need for
data scientists to shift context between
aspects like data analytics data science
and machine learning
that is right on and here is an exciting
announcement to all of the developers
we are adding a postgres interface
for spanner which continues our
commitment to openness and reinforces
our efforts to democratize the access to
spanner with this new postgres interface
enterprises can take advantage of
spanner's unmatched global scale
five nines of availability and strong
consistency using skills and tools from
the popular postgres ecosystem and
starting today you can create a spanner
database that uses postgres sql dialect
and connect with its open wire protocol
this interface supports banner's rich
feature set using the most popular
postgres data types and sql features and
thus democratizing access to spanner for
millions of developers out there our
commitment to the ecosystem has been
long standing with ongoing support for
cloud sql for mysql postgres and sql
server so you can lift and shift your
databases
our mission with cloud sql is
compatibility and we were the first
cloud provider to support postgres 13.
these announcements are so exciting
because postgres has emerged as a
popular choice for operational databases
postgres is known and love for its
stability and feature set and has built
an active and growing ecosystem of
developers and tools
our investments in postgres are a step
in the right direction to continue
meeting developers where they are with
the tools they love we are excited to
announce new ways to help organizations
going beyond traditional business
intelligence to analyze access and act
on data looker continues to integrate
with the other offerings in our
portfolio as well as continues to
innovate with our core product and to
address the needs we are continuing to
simplify the experience across bigquery
looker and data studio together with
connected sheets today we are announcing
new enhancements which bring the reality
of augmented analytics to more people
with looker's solution for contact
center ai to help businesses leverage ai
and converse naturally with customers
and deliver outstanding experiences
we are also announcing a new looker
block for healthcare nlp ai which
creates a user interface to advanced ai
and natural language functionality and
this helps healthcare providers to gain
deeper understandings of their patient
data part of the secret sauce lies in
lookers in database architecture and the
semantic layer which makes it possible
for business users to trust data no
matter how they experience it via a
dashboard email or text alert or even a
custom application
we are excited for these recent
innovations but we couldn't do this
alone together with our community of
customers partners and developers we are
delivering innovation across a variety
of use cases we are able to create new
solutions and accelerate your journey to
transform data into value
next i want to announce an important
partnership with informatica we have
partnered with informatica to help
hundreds of customers succeed with their
journey to the cloud
together we are helping customers move
mission critical workloads to the cloud
and integrate with google cloud
technologies such as bigquery
today we are excited to announce that we
are deepening our partnership with
informatica even more first for existing
informatica power center customers
we are so pleased to announce our
migration factory which will help to
accelerate migration of data-driven
workloads to google cloud with
informatica cloud
second
we are pleased to announce our new
services on google cloud's marketplace
which will include informatica's
integration and enterprise data catalog
offerings
and we are continuing to invest in key
product integrations with data bricks
our engineering and product teams
continue to work together to deliver the
joint roadmap and we have multiple
customers using our latest enterprise
security and performance enhancements of
databricks on gke in q4 we will also
deliver data brick sql databricks photon
on google cloud as well as we are
launching new data center regions
together in emea and apec
our ai teams are engaged to allow
customers to experiment and develop
models on data bricks and vertex ai
together and deploy models at scale into
production with vertex ml ops suite so
much goodness okay before we get into
the live demo i recommend tuning in to
more sessions to hear from all our
customers this week join the chief data
officer panel discussion and listen to
our product strategy sessions for
database data analytics bi and ai
we can't wait to hear from you connect
with you join us in our community and
share your expertise and ask you
questions but most importantly start to
build your data cloud and unlock your
data advantage
okay
time now to get hands on and check out
our products in real action
join us for a live demo and interact
with our experts and one another and
then stick around for the live q a
following the demo
i see you there